also ich würde nicht mehr leben können
unnötig ich hab noch ich glaube ich
hätte auch gedacht wenn du nicht da
gewesen wäre hätte ich mir einfach mal
gehabt hätte ich jetzt an typen der
genauso wie max damit cool weil ich bin
klar nie und das sehr schön behinderter
der liebe kong crafter und auch für luca
so ein kleines fragen video aufgenommen
und das ist voll - eigentlich bei wir
waren so gedreht und jetzt sehe ich alle
leute die mich behindert angucken lukas
nur von der seite gesehen
auf jeden fall was war ihr lustigstes
gemeinsames erlebnis
das haben wir auf jeden fall da es auf
sylt erlebt das war als flug eines
abends nach hause gefahren ist und dann
hat er 13 fahren weil gerade diese
strafe notiz müssen irgendwie finde ich
kaufe fahrrad und ich war ein wenig an
gewicht ich habe das milchgetränk an dem
abend und ich habe ihn seine sprache
tipps geschickt in seiner gruppe und
jetzt geschieht gerade 13 fahrräder
folge leistet so göttlich aber wir
brauchen die rechte
ja die weinkönigin ich die sprache -
damals das wird vielleicht auch gar
keinen sohn eines video weiß gar nicht
so viele fragen gibt hallo und löwen
agiert hier auch als gefragt was macht
ihr gerade auto bzw
draußen vertieft er dass dieselben
fragen gefragt aber wir gerade seht wir
beantworten fragen von twitter und so
und gleich gestern frankfurt würde ihr
euch ein alter die fragen uns alle
dieselben fragen vielleicht anders beide
verlinkt würdet ihr auch ein leben ohne
ohne euch bei luca und bei dir
vorstellen
also ich würde mit mehr leben können
ohne dich hab ich glaube ich hätte auch
gedacht wenn du nicht da gewesen wäre
hätte ich einfach mal wer dich jetzt an
typen ja genauso wie max damit cool
sind es eigentlich meine fahne oder
deinen nächsten
was war das kranke was ihr je erlebt hat
ich verstehe es so was war das kran
meine geburtsstadt halle auf das social
hingestellt clan päckchen gestellt
wieder hin weiter weg und du kommst hast
du denn gemacht
jetzt ist ein bisschen schief aber halb
so wild auf mich macht ihr ein
fantreffen in den ferien ich mache
vielleicht mal eins wenn ich irgendwo
bin bei luca ist es ja noch eine andere
sache mit seinen 30 august da kommen
dann wahrscheinlich auch 20 leute erst
mal voll beschäftigt mit dem kran
dahinten kranich kennen nur noch grab
die kommt kommt ja hin
man sieht man so ein bisschen da drüben
aber wegen fisch als ich auf jeden fall
weit weg von lukas stativ um
sie fanden dass eure freunde dass die
youtube macht also wandern für oder hier
studie finden finden
also meine freunde finden das voll in
ordnung bzw finden ist sogar ziemlich
cool eigentlich wie es bei di luca hilfe
es werde ihr eine stelle arbeitet da ich
mache hat youtube mit seinem anderen mit
dem faktor davon so ein bisschen
bekannter ist ja sonst ist das
eigentlich weiß nicht was ich sagen
können die samen bronze daneben
ich könnte sagen ich finde es cool oder
sagen einfach gar nichts sondern sie gar
nicht so finden sich cool einer
folgerichtigen platter werde ich hab's
genauso hingeschmissen sieht man
vielleicht das direkt so einfach wie
eine kerze auf den auf den spannenden
wie war eure kinder also meine ich
gerade schon wieder geräumt
neben jetzt gar nichts wie war eure
kinder in meinem war scheiße ich wurde
immer geschlagen vergewaltigt mann du
warst herzlich und den fünf stellen ich
schaute mir unbedingt in müllers wieder
vorbei die tage da hab ich nämlich
gerade ein bisschen gebraucht im
internet und wird
erwischt ich habe schon wieder ein jahre
gefasst schlag mehr auf die haben's ja
warte schon mal auf einem konzert wenn
ja von wem ich war schon auf einigen
konzerten das letzte wo ich war
prinz pi in würzburg was wir dann könnte
ich war bei calvin harris einfach nur
herr ist ja vielleicht noch mal irgendwo
ich glaube ich war sogar mal einfach bei
so einem festival
ich glaube das war serengeti da kommt ja
voll spaß mit seinem brötchen wieder
nein jetzt muss wieder laut schneller
youtube man den film ich zeigt im
wechsel glaubt es wird doch mal ein
youtuber geben der so schnell erfolg hat
wie ungespielt alle ist doch schon
jemand der eigentlich genauso gut abgeht
oder also er hat jetzt auch ein relativ
kurzer zeit ziemlich viele neue
abonnenten dazu bekommen sie nur
gespielt hat er komplett neu angefangen
hatte hatte ja schon vorher mit cache
und mit mich kennt man auch schon drei
jahre dabei
hier winken wenn man super fakt
ich habe gesagt ist es auch dass es
immer schwerer jetzt auch bekannt zu
werden
die hat stimmt da eigentlich ist echt
von tag zu tag schwerer weil jeden tag
den sich jemand alternativen ja jeden
tag denkt sich irgendjemand zu ja ich
bitte nicht so eingespielt und macht
sich dann kanal aber es ist
wahrscheinlich schon möglich toyotas
teil aber ist auf jeden fall ziemlich
schwierig also nicht möglich oder gar
nicht laut das geht schon klar das ist
sehr berühmt
ich suche noch eine weitere frage heraus
wir machen einfach nur sechs minuten
video uncut und so und gut lieber donut
oder muffin stalker sind so jeden recht
ich mag damals voll nicht alter ich
werde also dort sind zwar geil und süß
und zu aber das ist einfach so viel
gewalt hat zucker und so machen zu
schoko muffins von dr oetker sind so
geil von dr oetker was ich feiere sind
blau bremer fans glauben von von subway
die mafia sind auch marco aber die kurve
die gucken weil man hilfreiche nicht
subway klar
starbucks aber die cookies von von
subway sind sowieso feierabend
feierabend richtig was habt ihr für
david gesagt für dieses was habt ihr für
die zukunft geplant wieder also ich gehe
noch beschließen damit video ich ziehe
nach berlin nach hamburg
nein ich ziehe nach berlin habe ich echt
froh als ich will nach meinen erst mal
ein jahr frei machen indem ich halt in
berlin wohne so ein bisschen job oder so
eine scheiße mache
ich habe ihn gerührt